we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
good question do i just tell the
audience what i think on this show or do
i calculate what i say based on who i
perceive the audience to be take a
listen i David my name is Jacob
I've a huge fan of yours I'm a third
year law student in Colorado my question
for you is very simple do you feel as a
taco kind of host especially more
meaning to the left that you are able to
give your firm and unbiased opinion all
the time or do you feel that sometimes
you have to tell the audience kind of
what they want to hear I guess it's more
of like an integrity question do you
feel that you are able to be yourself
without telling the audience what you
think they want to hear are you able to
say what you want and have the risk of
having your audience title lash back out
and have yeah listen I do simply tell it
the way I see it and it sometimes causes
conflicts even within my core audience
and I I do not calculate what I think
the audience wants to hear number one
because I think it would be the wrong
thing to do I just want to do the show
the way I want to do it and that
includes just giving my views I don't
calculate what is going to give me the
sort of best outcome in terms of how the
audience will react and then from a
practical standpoint nobody is going to
be pleased not you will never please
everyone no matter what position you
take so I made the decision long ago
I'll just tell it the way I see it
period
and you can disagree with me you can say
I'm a bad person for what I believe but
I'm telling you what I believe and I
will continue to do that we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
become a member or a patron by signing
up at david pakman.com slash membership
or patreon.com slash david pakman show
which will give you instant access to
the bonus show